so something big lately that's been
taken up an awful lot of my time I
haven't had quite the usual amount of
time to record videos I've been super
busy with this thing it's very important
I can't tell you what it is but yet
she's been eating up my time an awful
lot so I thought I'd try and make a
slightly quicker video today and I have
just the thing here to look at it is a
power worker
[Music]
so this isn't anything new it speaks of
equipment you possibly seen before but I
do find it's gone a little bit out of
those you don't tend to hear people
talking about it that often I think
that's a shame so I think it's quite a
cool piece of gadgetry so in case you
haven't seen this before the idea is
simple it is a bar that you can push or
pull or bend like so and it offers up
resistance in this case this one claimed
that it provides up to 110 pounds of
resistance so when I do this a bit
squeaky fish and basically doing a text
slide and it's broken video means you
don't need a whole resistance machine in
your house but it can do a whole bunch
of other stuff too for instance you're
supposed to be able to pull these and
then these clips like that I mean all
that is in the picture shows a guy doing
bicep curls
but I find that is a little sketch more
useful is pressing down on the top of
this process on the floor and do a kind
of tricep pushdown in the picture it
also has people doing it with their arms
behind their back I don't know how its
let's go to do that
the main reason I really like it is
because I can insert into bag if I'm
going on a trip and then I can work out
you know at my parents house or my
friend's house without having to carry
around dumbbells with me and looking
like a special person the other thing
that makes is quite interesting is the
fact that it's great for overcoming
isometrics that means an isometric
exercise where you're pushing as hard as
you can against an immovable force
likewise it's useful for yielding
isometrics means you just holding the
thing in place like slow so you might
push it halfway and then just hold it
there like this and as you'll know if
you've watched my previous video
isometric training is a great way to
build the mind muscle connection to
increase muscle fiber recruitment and to
generally improve your strength and it's
not that easy to do always because you
know if you want to do pecs doing some
form of isometric training then your
only real options are is to hold
dumbbells above you which could drop on
the floor this is training at home of
course or to hold yourself in a better
position which isn't offering that much
resistance or some push against the wall
which is not that comfortable and
involving leg strips as much as your arm
so this is a great way to do that kind
of training for your tech and to
increase your kind of crushing power and
crushing power is cool on here it says
to hold each position for seven seconds
in order to get the full benefits into
repeat several times and I can attest so
that will indeed work help you build up
some strength what happens is when you
push something and hold the position and
it requires a lot of force the brain is
forced to use as much as the fast twitch
muscle fiber as possible call into
action just as though you were doing
your want one rep max
you know it gets the point where muscle
fiber sucks the Tegan needs to bring in
other ones by doing that you can
actually increase your ability to call
upon your maximum strength when requires
and studies show the training with this
kind of isometric either even either
very intense yielding isometric or
overcoming isometric has been using a
lot of strength will build up your net
max and your grip strengths and your
crushing strength in just the same way
the training with incredibly heavy
weights will but it's much more
convenient because packed into that sort
of thing you're not going to drop weight
on you and also the movement is
something to be very hard to replicate
with all run one rep max so yeah this is
how brutally train for strength is
you'll never watched my Bruce Lee
training videos and it's how others like
Dennis Rogers and many proper strongmen
trained so if you want to integrate that
into your routine then isometric
training is a great way to do that and
also this is a great way to do that of
course we're in looking at our text here
and our triceps and maybe a vise lift
you're going to come with more methods
for training other body parts in an
isometric way but as a starting point
this is pretty good and I will be doing
a video in future on the best isometric
exercises you can do to build strength
and crushing power so stay tuned for
that one there's a the joints a little
bit
but it's a cool thing nonetheless
definitely something different to throw
into your training certainly useful to
bring on a trip
and I find myself stay often using its
Duty tricep pushdown but also for a
bunch of other stuff so why don't you
just pick up when you go into the room
get a little bit of strength training
can drop it down without having worked
up a sweat or lap to move around your
whole room so yeah in fact that is
porcel as well is the bonus you can find
this on all sorts of websites like
Amazon and fitness sites and it's not
just called a power bar you can also see
a quarter power worker a bull worker
doesn't bull working it should come up
but yeah let me know you think you use
one of these is something you might add
to your own collection thanks so much
for watching guys this family's useful
please consider liking sharing and
subscribing and I'll catch the next one
bye for now